[Applaudissements]
enfin si ce poids est 6e
j'aime bien pire
parce que je vois tu amorces de vie dure
à des magazines avec
et c'est un film dans lequel on rit
beaucoup dans lequel vous vous buvez
beaucoup dans lequel tous les auteurs de
l'émission qu'ont préparé avec moi sont
fous encore plus de géraldine nakache
ah oui il ya une scène qui les a laissés
voilà toutes les scènes de formidable
dans le film et et tout le monde et tous
les auteurs sont amoureux de vous avouer
c'est ce petit massage vous êtes mais un
massage très chaste un bidon mais bien
sûr on part dans ma tasse on ne voit
rien je vous dis on ne voit rien mais ça
leur salle aura suffi on est encore au
bureau ça premier tour nous et géraldine
géraldine j'avoue j'en rêverai voilà
qu'elle me masse dans mais c'est vrai
car ils sont tous comme des fous ce soit
ce qu'on aurait pu déjà boire un café
mais on les équipe là est